foreign
[Music]
from director Darren Aronofsky one of my
very first calls was to my makeup artist
Adrian Moreau can we do something that's
incredibly realistic no pressure that's
the first thing and then the next thing
he said is that oh by the way we're
gonna see him nude he's gonna have short
sleeves he's going to have short pants
and we ended up having 12 weeks to build
the makeup
what a great chance to create these two
iconic characters well one iconic
character and then the villain and then
really the other bit was Elvis's
progression you know the more Tom Parker
got his claws into Elvis it manifested
in the way he looked right through where
he sings on Chen Melody several weeks
before he passed away
every day was like I started in the
night and I finished in the night he had
like 200 soldiers every day everyone
with like wigs or facial hair dirt teeth
because we didn't want it to have the
white teeth any more than marching to
set basically to the battlefield and
what you have seen in front of camera it
looked the same behind the camera
certainly one of the standout makeups in
the movie is the Penguin it's not a
makeup it's a complete and utter
transformation of Colin Farrell I looked
at it at a different perspective Matt
Reeves had some ideas about how he was a
little bit like Fredo from The Godfather
I said how can I incorporate a penguin
in here I felt like it was kind of a
culmination of all the makeups that Mike
and I have done and really using almost
every trick in the book
this movie was all about the women you
see there's very few minutes actually
and it's about their connection
one of the main things that I think
about wakanda forever is that it's a
franchise that could have been over
because we lost our star what kind of
movie gets a chance to come back as a
rebirth and we got that opportunity and
that's the most beautiful thing
thank you